un cas avéré de dengue aux anses d'arlet
et 3a redoute
ajoutons à cela des dizaines de cas
suspects chaque semaine la dengue est de
retour
de plus avec deux virus différents le 1
et le 3 facteur aggravant car une même
personne pourrait contracté la dengue
deux fois dans la saison même si ce
fléau nous épargne mystérieusement
depuis presque trois ans les équipes
sont toujours sur le terrain
de janvier à décembre nous ramenons
c'est là où cela nous permet de faire
des tests en laboratoire donc des tests
de résistance par rapport aux produits
insecticides et ça nous permet aussi de
faire de l'identification de moustiques
puisque nous sommes aussi là dans le
cadre d'une surveillance d'autres
espèces qui peuvent entrer sur le
territoire en 1ère s une nouvelle
campagne de prévention est en
préparation et partout où des cas de
dengue seront confirmés tout une enquête
de quartier sera diligentée dans la
maison du cas où là on va faire des
recherches de gîtes on va faire de
l'éducation sanitaire on va faire
éventuellement des traitements
insecticides
on va faire également autour de du foyer
du cac on va faire une enquête en tomo
épidémiologique
c'est à dire que l'on va rechercher dans
le quartier s'il ya d'autres personnes
qui présentent des symptômes de la de la
dengue pour essayer de voir s'il ya
d'autres cas et s'il ya un départ de
foyers épidémiques information des
riverains et destruction des gîtes
seront bien sûr effectué à noter que
l'arrivée possible d'une sécheresse
prolongée ne serait pas un frein au
développement de l'internet la vigilance
ne doit donc pas se relâcher